good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to our second meeting at
killer marsh sports centre
as i said when we met in june many
things had to change when we had to work
virtually
and which i would like to carry forward
now that we are meeting physically
the more structured approach worked well
at our last meeting and i suggest we
follow a similar approach this time
but before we begin i would be grateful
if the principal clerk could explain how
the meeting will run
and what we need to do and which members
are here thank you
thank you chair um so just a few health
and safety announcements for today
welcome to killer martian apologies to
everybody for the late change of venue
we do have social distancing in
operation here on site today
and hand sanitizer around the room for
your use
if you've got any concerns or
requirements please indicate it to a
member of the staff and we will help to
assist you
we're not expecting a fire alarm today
during the course of the meeting
therefore if one does sound that we'll
be treating it as a true alert and we'll
be exiting via the two doors here
and heading out around to the car park
as the chair requested i would just like
to announce which members
are present here with us today we have
councillor armitage councillor elliot
councillor jones
councillor powell councillor ridgeway
councillor rouse
councillor ruff councillor and cliff and
councillor dayton
and also um here today with us we have
members of the planning team
um graham emily and adrian jim fields
and our legal advisor and members of the
governance team who will be here today
to support
thank you chair thank you
first item on the agenda are apologies
for absence
thank you chair we've got apologies for
absence today from councillor heather
liggett who's substituted today by
councillor pat ancliff
and apologies also from councillor mark
foster who is substituted today
by councillor lillian dayton there's
also apologies from roger hall
[Applause]
are there any other apologies
non-received chair
second item on the agenda is declaration
of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already on
their register of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
have we received any declarations in
advance and non-received an advanced
chair
no do any members have a declaration of
interest
non-seizure thank you item three
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the meeting minutes of the meeting held
on tuesday the 29th of june
2021 are we all happy that they are a
correct record
of a mover and a seconder is councillor
and cliff
and secondary is councillor armitage
all those in favor
thank you any abstentions
any against the motions carried
thank you members that moves us onto our
main business for today
we have five applications and one
provisional
tree preservation order to consider as
you can see each of these has its own
report marked as a gender items four to
nine
i am happy with this and intend to
consider them in that order
before we do this i would like the clark
to explain for the benefit
of members speakers and the public
and those who will listen to the audio
recording that we
that will be made about how we will deal
with the applications and the
provisional tpo
[Applause]
yes uh thank you chair this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting
we will consider the four applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
although there will be a break during
the proceedings
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was
issued the late items agenda supplement
has been published on the council's
website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
members have received hard copies of
this which they are asked to follow
after this the chair will ask each of
the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors
then the applicant or their agent to
speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee
will have an opportunity to ask the
speakers questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote the votes
will be taken by a roll call
a note for the speakers once the
application you've come to speak on has
been dealt with
you may leave the meeting if you choose
to remain
then please be aware that you will not
be allowed to participate further
from that point as you're aware
this meeting is being recorded and this
recording will be placed on the
council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this from the internet
thank you chair thank you
we'll move on to the first application
which is item 4 which is ned
stroke 21 forward stroke 00393
stroke outline permission for shilland
but before we move on to that
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any late comments reports
that have been produced and for the
planning manager
to give a brief presentation showing any
photos
and plans of the site these are in the
pack that has been
circulated to you therefore i will allow
the officers to complete their
presentation
i ask members to reserve any points of
order or questions about the process
until the end there will be plenty of
time for questions later
thank you
[Applause]
thank you chair just firstly may i refer
members to the late representations
report that was emailed out to them
yesterday afternoon
the paper version chair that before all
members
today was printed off before that report
was completed
and we've got a very late representation
so it doesn't contain that so
for clarity chair i'm just going to read
the summation
of that other representation which
members will have seen
in electronic form but isn't in the
paper form before you
this afternoon and in effect it's from
um timothy slack who lives at 15
northfield
and he sets out that currently
northfield is a private cul-de-sac
offering its residents
a peaceful community with no issues of
crime it already has a sufficient foot
entry and exit point where it meets town
end
there is no need for a foot battling
from birkenstyle lane into the site
or vice versa and it can therefore be
considered unnecessary
thereby failing the test for a condition
as per the submission
of the agent charlotte stanton he goes
on to
reiterate comments made by keith besik
of derbyshire police chair
who has commented that narrow links
emerging into semi-private space
are a known generator of nuisance
problems for adjacent houses
footpaths are such narrow links given
the issues arising from any footpaths
elsewhere
why take such risk when none persists at
present
and there is no demonstrable reason to
install the proposed footpath
and he concludes for the reasons
documented in this memo
he supports the application to remove
footpath link
and as contained within condition 28.
just in terms of the detailing checks an
application as you
have just outlined to remove a footpath
link as required by condition 28 of
planning consent
ned1200718
ol the site visit yesterday chair noted
a range of views of the site of
birkenstar lane and town end
but we have included a few photographs
showing that in the presentation pack
that members do have
the approved scheme for the site chair
required a link from the development to
birkenstyle lane
for the reason that it was in the
interest of pedestrian safety and
therefore members will need to take that
into account
in considering the application officer's
view
chair is that it would however lead to a
narrow route bounded by high fencing
there was no right way through the site
previously
and as you've just heard the designing
out crime officer mr bezick supports the
application to remove the link
officers consider a suitable alternative
is available along town end and
birkenstyle lane
and conclude that the harm likely to
result from retaining the link
is not outweighed by any benefits
just in terms of the photographs in the
presentation
share the the first one as is customary
shows the site
hatched in orange it's shown on there is
partially
developed the
the second slide shows the site outlined
in red and you can make out the link
to the west to town end and then the
link
to the north to birkenstyle lane
and the follows a location plan of the
scheme as approved and as
developed now out and again you can see
the
vehicle access onto town end and then
the link of the site to birkenstar lane
at the north of the site next to number
10
between it and number 18. and then share
just two
to move on the the next slide shows the
development as approved showing that
footpath link
in front of one of the properties and
then linking through the area of green
space
towards burke and star lane it's that
link and the requirement for that link
that the application seeks to remove all
of the elements of the application would
remain
unaltered and then finally chair as i
say there are a small number of
photographs showing
the details of the application the first
photograph shows the entrance into the
site from birkenstar lane that the
footpath link
would go into so it's between the two
houses as you can see there and then
accessing past the new property in the
middle distance
further to that chair the next
photograph shows the
view of the link provision
westwards along birkenstyle lane
and then we move on to some photographs
of town end and
officers have put those into the
presentation chair just to outline that
there is an alternative
route along birkenstein lane and town
end that connects the two
points of the site and moving on chair
the
next slide is of the site entrance
and then further that into the site
and then the final two slides show where
the footpath link would go along
a private drive towards the timber fence
in the middle distance
and then the final slide shows a a
close-up of that
showing where the footpath link would go
through the front
of the property that's been built and
then accessing onto birkenstar lane
between the two properties again in the
middle distance where there's a
tree or or large bush just at the moment
thank you chair thank you
i'm now going to invite the speakers to
address the committee
as the clerk explained they will each
have three minutes
to get over their points they will be
informed when 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been raised
but remember your question should only
relate to the points which you have
already made
our speakers are here today with us and
they will address us from the desk
having said that one of the speakers
couldn't arrive today because of the
late change of venue and her work
commitments
but the clerk is going to read out the
text
yes thank you chair this is from anne
brown
chair of sherland and heim parish
council and a statement is to begin
all our parish councillors feel very
strongly about this footpath
and that it should remain there are
concerns that if condition 28 is removed
the developer will build additional
properties in the open space
although a footpath across the front
garden of number three is not ideal
the developer was well aware of this
condition that was agreed regarding the
footpath
in the 2012 application decision
the idea of a footpath to birkenstyle
lane arose from the public consultation
the developers description said that a
new public health path
will be providing will will be provided
linking the site to birkenstyle lane
this will provide people living on the
development and on town end a quick
and easy route to the bus stop to bus
stop on birkenstyle lane
and to the facilities at stone broom
this footpath is very well used and is
an important link for the elderly
resident
residents in nearby school close
the police report that shelton stington
is relying on as evidence
is dated 21st june 2016
well before the landscaping and
driveways were put in this condition was
included for very good reasons
and should not be removed thank you
chair that's the end of the statement
thank you does anyone want any
clarification on the text
no thank you i have one other speaker
and
speaking on behalf of the applicant lee
evans
mr evans if you'd like to take the desk
if you'd like to confirm your name and
then you have three minutes uh
lee evans thank you my name is lee evans
my company built this small development
of 14 homes
and my wife and i have now chosen to
live in one of them as part of the
sherlin community
we are not a big developer from outside
the area trying to get away with a
planning condition
i was always concerned about the issues
associated with the provision of the new
link
and now the house at plot 3 has been
constructed we are even more concerned
about the potential impacts
the new link would create a long narrow
path with six foot fencing to each side
and therefore there would be very
limited natural surveillance
this would enable people to loiter
unseen at the side of the existing house
at 18 birkenstown lane
as well as at the side of the garden
associated with plot 3.
this is a serious potential security and
anti-social behavior problem
the proposed footpath link serves no
useful purpose
you may have seen a plan submitted by a
local resident which shows that the
length of the route from birkenstar lane
to town end will actually be longer
one of the main things i want to explain
today is that there seems to be some
confusion about this path
this is not an existing footpath or
right of way that we are trying to close
we think the objectors are confusing
another permissive footpath in the area
with the proposed link there have been
comments that the footpath has been used
for hundreds of years
which can't be true when it hasn't even
been constructed
although not relevant to this
application i want to confirm
for the record that the permissive
footpath that i think is being referred
to in the objections
was closed after plot 5 was plot 8 was
sold
as the builder i maintained access all
of the time
in summary this is not an existing
public footpath
it is only a proposed tarmac link
between two fences
from my development to the road it would
serve no useful purpose to the existing
residents of sherland
there is simply no need for this
footpath link the footpath link
is likely to cause anti-social behavior
issues for the existing sherlin
residents
as well as the residents in the new
homes the crime prevention officer
at the police has given you strong
advice that this footpath should not be
built
we ask you please to agree with your
officer recommendation
and let us complete the development
without this unnecessary link
thank you thank you
members do you have any questions to
clarify
councillor powell um hello i'm strong
um is the development complete now
virtually apart from the final servicing
of the road yeah
it's just that i get the feeling that
we've been backed into a corner here
because
there doesn't seem to be any attempt
made
in the stages that you've completed to
actually do anything about the footpath
and i would have thought that bearing in
mind
it was a condition originally you would
have worn that in mind when you were
doing it i also find it surprising that
you didn't realize it was going to be
difficult until one of the houses was
complete
your comments please i think we did
realize that it was it was going to be
an issue
um the footpath link was actually added
in the outline
application um we did a reserve matters
application where
it wasn't we were unable to remove it at
that point um i take
i take on board the comments that it's
taken some time
i think that's purely down to resource
and time as a small company
you know i'm sort of running the
business on my own so i don't think
there's anything machiavellian about it
it's just
just timing
thank you councillor anchor sorry
councillor armitage
thank you chair i must uh agree with my
colleague
you knew about uh condition 28
when you were started the the thing and
surely
when you put the application into to
start with
wouldn't it have been better uh to
not have condition 2018 at the time
or was it just apply mainly to get a
uh get to get planning permission
and bearing in mind you mentioned
unsociable
uh things and the police and what have
you but there's a police
house just uh opposite i mean you know
there are police
nice and near to stop anti-social
behavior
don't you agree well actually the police
house was closed a few decades ago
it's now a shop with regard to the
planning permission
i repeat that the we weren't we didn't
put the outline application in we only
did a reserved matters application
and there was no there was no way oh
well there's no legal way
that a condition can be removed from the
outline um
from the outline application with via
the the reserve matters
so we couldn't actually do it at the
time anyway
thank you any other questions i can
answer earlier
counselor elliot thank you chair looking
at the
looking at the map is it not possible to
make that footpath
wider and does it have to be hemmed in
with six foot
fence panels
um i suppose it could be yeah because
because i'm assuming that
you're saying the antisocial behaviors
because they could loiter
within that six foot fence panel in a
narrow void
it doesn't have to be a narrow void
looking at it i don't think the fact
that it's narrow is the issue i think
the fact that it's you're not going to
get
natural surveillance i mean i'm not an
expert on it we're only just taking what
the police have told us
any further questions no
thank you
we now have the college now have the
opportunity to put questions to the
planning manager
and any other officers about the
application
again i would like to keep this part of
our proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points that you are
not sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on what we have all heard and read
i would be grateful
if you could not move any motions at
this stage
thank you are there any questions for
the
planning offices counsellor
ow thank you chair um yeah
question to the planning manager really
there seems to be some dispute about
whether this footpath ever existed
um and it's a pity that the
representative from the parish council
couldn't be here to answer questions on
the assertion that it is well used um
i'm i'm in some difficulty here because
if it doesn't exist how can it be well
used
and i i just i mean a dilemma about it
so
any comment would be welcome mr kirkham
all i can advise members chairs that
there is no formal right of way
through the site so if there were
permissions
to use the land to gain access between
town and birkenstown lane it was never
enshrined as a formal public right of
way so i presume it was
permissive or or allowed by any previous
owners if it existed at all
i can't advise any any further than that
i'm afraid
thank you are there any further
questions counselor armitage
yes uh adrian i mean why was condition
28 put on that in the first place and
why did you why
was it allowed condition 28 was
placed on the the outline application as
i mentioned
in the introduction chair it was placed
on in the interests of pedestrian safety
it was
undertaken in 2012 or there are there
about so it is some time ago so i can't
recall
the exact detailing of that but the
application
was approved with that condition
requiring the foot
footpath link in the interest of
pedestrian safety so that is
i'm i'm presuming in our advice to you
that's the issue that you need to
consider whether
or not it is a requirement for
the link to be retained to allow
appropriate access to and from bookstore
lane to and from
town and from the development also to
allow access
around the site otherwise is that an
acceptable form of
alternative and of course you've also
got the issue of what as well as well
does the the design of the development
and does that
um is that deteriorated by not having
the links i think they're the two issues
chair that members need to take into
account and as officers
the view that we've set out is that
there is an acceptable alternative link
potentially shorter for those who want
to travel along burkestar lane and town
end
between the two entrance points and so
that's in effect led to our
recommendation to members along with the
advice that mr bezick's
given to us in terms of the designing
out crime officer comments
thank you councillor elliot yeah good
question for adrian
adrian i'm sort of this is in addition
to what a councillor armitage has just
asked
if if there's never been a footpath
there and the section 28 was sat there
was that just sat there so there was a
footpath should we call it footpath or
not
was it just sat there while the site was
being developed
as an accessible route through because
it just for me it just seems like a
shortcut and nothing more
that's to say the the um negotiation
that was undertaken
at the outline application is some it's
almost 10 years ago so i can't recall
the exact detailing but
it would have it would be our normal um
normal process
and our normal stance to seek to ensure
that new development is accessible so
there is access
through and to other rights away and in
this instance
having that access onto birkentown lane
would have ticked one of those boxes
allowing access from the development to
birkenstar lane
therefore meaning that anyone wanting to
access from the development
to birkenstyle lane doesn't have to go
on the the route around
and would we would we have just put that
on as a temporary measure
because you know if you put a load of
slabs down round
around somebody's house somebody'll cut
across the grass is it is it just that
kind of issue
no it was it was put on as a condition
requiring that link
so not not as a temporary measure
are there any further questions
no thank you adrian
this leads us on to the final part of
the process our discussion about what
we've heard what we think and what we
want to decide
but before going any further i would
just like the clerk to remind us about
motions
thank you chair please bear in mind
members
that a motion must be moved and seconded
before the vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved in
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving the motion
against officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject offers
recommendations fails
or in other words it is not passed that
doesn't mean to say that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you chair thank you i'd like to
open the floor for debate again as the
clerk has just reminded us could you
please refrain from moving any motions
until we have concluded any discussion
thank you does anyone want to open the
floor
counselor pal um as i said earlier i
think we've been backed into a corner
here
um i'm very disappointed that
no action towards putting in a footpath
has been taken and that
the houses have been built however
um in a practical sense i don't think we
have much of a choice
i think we should also think about the
residents who now live there
um so when the time comes to move a
motion
i will be supporting officer's
recommendation
thank you any other comment
no i'll open the floor for a motion to
be put in place
counselor pal move officer's
recommendation chair
i'd like to second it
can we have a show of hands oh no nikki
we have to have a roll call don't we
absolutely thank you thank you chair as
seems to be
custom for this authority we'll take um
a recorded vote style
um roll call um starting um with
alphabetic reverse could you clearly
state for
against or abstain for the motion put
councillor rough four council rouse
four castle ridge bay
four councillor powell four
council jones
council elliot four casa dayton
or casa armitage or
castle and cliff four chair with nine
votes four zero against zero
substantials is carried
thank you thank you members the motion's
been carried
we can move on to the second application
for the afternoon
application 21 forward slash oh no i'm
reading the same one out again aren't i
sorry i need to check the page
[Applause]
42. i'm going to go through that again
okay we're now on application
21 forward slash zero zero one nine one
forward slash fl this is an application
of the construction of two agricultural
buildings again in sherland
thank you chair firstly maya confirmed
that no light reps have been received on
this application
in terms of the detailing this is a full
application for the construction of two
agricultural buildings atlanta the
northeast of main road sherland members
of planning committee attended a virtual
site visit of the site where we saw a
range of photos
officers consider that the proposal
would be for an operation of a use
appropriate to its countryside location
the scale design and sighting of the
building is considered to be in keeping
with the character
and appearance of the surrounding
countryside which would preserve the
setting of the listed building on site
the proposed development would not
result in any adverse
detrimental impacts upon the privacy and
amenity of nearby residential properties
or neighbouring land uses nor would it
lead to an adverse impact upon highway
safety
as you can see in the pack chair this
plan illustrates the site shaded in
orange
as you can see the site is located to
the east of main road and is cited
outside of the defined settlement
development limit of sherland
and is considered a countryside location
on the next slide the application field
and access
is edged in red and the applicant's land
holding is edged in blue
this next slide shows the proposed block
plan the two agricultural buildings
would be cited within close proximity to
one another
within the southwest corner of the field
moving on this is an elevation and floor
plan illustrating building one which
will be used for the storage of
agricultural machinery and implements
this next slide illustrates the
elevation and floor plan for building 2
which will be used for the storage
of hay and the shelter of livestock
the next slides are key photos taken
from the committee site visit which
members attended yesterday i've included
these as a refresher for members
thank you chair thank you
i'm going to invite the speakers but
again the kep the speaker that we had
from the parish council couldn't
attend so i'm going to ask the clerk to
read her text
yes thank you chad again this is the
text from
councillor ambrow the proposed buildings
are not in keeping with the nation of
the listed building
there are also concerns about the height
of these
we are very concerned regarding what the
buildings are to be used for
in particular the one stated for
livestock
this is too close to the existing
buildings and may lead to smells
problems with flies etc will there be a
stipulation that the buildings can only
be used for agricultural purposes
as we have seen in the past that an
application states one thing
then once the buildings are built are
used for totally different purposes
there also is a worth of course in close
proximity to this site
which causes us concerns i hope that you
will take our points raised into serious
consideration
making your re making your decision
regarding this application
thank you chair thank you does anyone
have any
uh clarification for the clerk
no thank you i'll then hand over to
any questions to the planning officer
councillor armitage yeah uh
could you actually uh see that there was
a need
for this i mean is there a holding
number on this particular
area
thank you councillor um yes there is a
agricultural holding number on the site
and when i visited the site there was a
more equestrian feel
that's because the previous owners did
use it for that however
the current applicant is proposing to
use it for agricultural purposes
thank you any other questions
comments i'd just like to raise
one and this is for the officers
probably adrian
if this application was to be passed
asian could we put on a condition that
if it was no longer used as agricultural
use the
buildings had to be demolished
if you felt chair that without that
condition
the development wasn't acceptable then
then you could
it's not um a condition that i've
come across before because it does
require significant
it would have a significant impact on
the applicant if he or she
erected the buildings and then had to
have them removed and so
would ask you to think carefully about
whether developed is otherwise
acceptable without it i think that's
that's the first issue but if you felt
that it
needed that condition on to give you
absolute surety that
the buildings would be used for
agriculture and without that
you wouldn't be ever mind to granted
content then yes
you could if you felt it met the the
necessary conditions to
and provide an acceptable form of
development the buildings
as you'd be aware chair should only be
used for agricultural purposes
should you grant consent any other use
would require planning consent
thank you any other questions to
councillor armitage yeah he said
in the uh
proposal that it the one building
is to be used uh for a hay barn
and uh in my experience if you put
in a building of this design it'll set
on fire
basically through internal combustion
because there's no ventilation
and you're gonna have a roller shutter
door and i don't think the design
is suitable for what it uh what it's
said is going to be useful quite frankly
if i may just just very briefly an emily
all correct if i'm wrong
he achieved i believe that the building
with the roller shutter doors is to be
used to store
the equipment and the building with the
front opening is is proposed to be used
for the hay storage
which i think is the point that council
army teachers made i'm
afraid i'm i'm no um expert on the combo
stability of hay but
um i think that would perhaps address
the point that casserole
made sure there's no roller shutter
there's no
uh shutters on the uh hay store
that's correct councillor so the second
building is open fronted on one side
right so it'll be open
say that again sorry it'll be an open
building yes that's correct
yes so building one would be for the
implement and machinery and that would
have the role of shutters and then the
building two
would be open sided and that would be
for the livestock and hay
thank you thank you
thank you any further questions
no thank you i'll open the floor for
debate
any comment no
i'll move it for a motion councillor
rich richard
oh sorry councillor ridgeway yeah i just
feel that i agree with
your comment chair that if we do approve
this that we um
we put a condition on that it stays
for what it is because what was read out
by one of the objectors i totally agree
we have had planning here before that
we've agreed
to be one thing and it's been turned
into something different so i think
if we do approve this i think we need to
set very strong conditions
thank you is there a
motion on the floor move officer
recommendation chair
thank you secondary chance thank you
with conditions that's the the point of
just seeking clarity on chair um
the comment that council ridgeway
mentioned was i think in response to
your question to me chen
we just need to be clear if members are
minded to grant permission whether it's
in
addition to a further condition that
requires the buildings to be
demolished if they are no longer used
for agriculture
and if that's the case chad um ask that
and if members are minded to grant
content
with that included that the final
wording of that is
uh is finalized with yourself um power's
delegated to me to
add that but in consultation with
yourself chair adrian through through
the chair i'm quite happy the conditions
are on that it remains nothing other
than agricultural
if if the chair would like to add the
condition that's demolished fine
thank you okay you just need clarity on
that point here whether
that condition goes on or not and i'm
not sure
um cancer elite whether you're asking
that the
as far as i'm concerned adrian we put
the condition on that it will always
remain agricultural
if somebody would like to add to that
anything
to to embellish that that's fine thank
you
we can sort that out then okay and just
to be clear then chair
members are voting to approve the the
application according with the
set out conditions with an additional
condition that requires the buildings to
be
demolished should they no longer be used
for agricultural purposes
is everyone happy with that do you need
that condition chair
sanitary can we just be clear then who
moved and seconded that motion
i moved it yeah i seconded it thank you
thank you thank you members
okay jerry have you for me to do the
vote
oh yes sorry i'm ahead of myself
we'll now take the vote thank you for
members
clearly indicate four against or abstain
councillor
armitage armitage and cancer and cliff
that's all in favour chair carried thank
you the motion's been carried
we'll move on to the third application
and then after that i
shall say we'll have a short break thank
you
this application is reference number
21 forward slash zero zero three
double four forward slash flh
and this is proposed loft conversion
with two front dormers
one rear dormer and hips covered to
gables
single storey rear extension at 95
windsor drive
thank you over to the planning officer
yes thank you chair
just first of all to refer members to
the
late representations that were emailed
out um yesterday afternoon in this
instance chair the
late reps that's referred to is
disappear in the hard copy so i don't
intend to
make further reference to it and members
will i'm sure
have already read that but in terms of
the the application chair it's an
application seeking to
add um rear and roof extensions to a
property that's currently a bungalow at
wingerworth so the applicant in this
instance is seeking to raise the height
of the
roof apex and add both front and rear
dormers
and also to add a single story rear
extension
site chair sits between a row of
two-story properties
and an extended bungalow and the
bungalow itself is currently brick built
the property would be raised by one
meter as i say the roof will be raised
by one meter
but following your seat of amended plans
both front and rear dormers would be
offset
from the side of the roof that abuts
with the
next door bungalow as noted
at the virtual site visit yesterday
chair the issues needing to be
considered
are the issue of the design of the
extension and its impact on
the amenity and the privacy of the
next-door neighbors
just to go through the slides chair
in order the first slide again outlines
the application
site in orange
and then over the page the the site has
is customary outlined in red
and then further to that chair the next
slide shows the bungalow in its current
form and you can see
on the rear there is currently a
conservatory and additional
element already on the rear there just
turning the page chair now
shows what's proposed so there are two
dormers proposed on the front elevation
and then
the side elevations show the raising of
the
roof apex by the one meter that i've
referred to
and then the front and rear dormers and
the rear extension
just in the bottom left of that slide as
we saw yesterday
you can see the revised plan showing the
rear door set away from the edge of the
property
and set down by the 700 mil from the
apex of the roof
you can also see chair the the various
windows that are referred to in the
report
the one nearest to the next draw
property is proposes a bedroom and then
there's a bathroom
a landing area another bathroom and then
the final one which is three paned
window
is a further bedroom
the next slide just shows the details on
plan form and in section form
and then in terms of the photographs
share the
application bungalow is the bungalow on
the left hand side of that photograph
and you can see
the next door property with the two
existing
front gables and you can just make out
the
secondary kitchen window that we
discussed at plan
at site visits yesterday providing the
secondary light
and to the the kitchen which has other
windows to the rear and rear side
and in terms of the street scene chair
the next slide shows the
two-story properties that lie next door
to the application
property which is to the right of the
photograph
and then the next slide shows what was
originally proposed in the
top left which was boarding whereas now
the materials to be used
to finish off the the roof are render
and then finally chair again as we saw
yesterday
the next slide shows on the right hand
side the application property
and then on the left of that the next
door property which is set down at the
lower level
from the application property then again
share on the left hand side
the left hand wall is of the neighboring
property
again you can see the difference in
levels with the level of the
next door bungalow down the level where
the bins are stored
and then finally the final slide
shows the or seeks to to show the issue
of
privacy and overlooking and the concerns
of the the next door neighbor is in
relation to the new windows that would
be installed
in the roof elevation which is the top
of that slide so where the
the ladder is accessing and so the end
of the property would become a gable
rather than the hip
and set in from there would be the new
box stormer with the windows
and the the issue that we've set out as
officers in the report is
that there would be some element of
and limited looking into the garden next
door but that would be offset by
the garage the existing extension of
course by the angle
and that's the view that we've set out
as officers in the report chair
thank you i shall now ask the speakers
to
karma and the first speaker is an
objector
a mr tag
mr tank could you just confirm your name
and then you have three minutes
yeah so mark tag
okay i strongly disagree that this
development is acceptable
even taking account of the slight
alterations
and it will be in effect like a
two-story flat roof house
with three unobscured windows angled
towards our garden
this will severely affect our privacy
and the height in real times
will severely affect the availability of
light through our kitchen window
size this at the rear will be a large
box-like structure and undeniably will
tower 6.4 meters
21 feet above our ground level and the
corner sits only 18
18 inches from our property i arrive at
6.4 meters
from the 5 meter height of the building
and the fact
that my ground level is 1.4 meters lower
than
the development this is contrary to the
stated figure
of 0.73 meters in the report in the
officer's measurement
no consideration of the nine courses of
break
the damp course was undertaken if you do
the development is actually 1.4 meters
higher not just
0.73 a slightly misleading statement
0.7.5 in the report this consequently
will have an increased effect on the
light in to my kitchen and privacy on my
garden
0.7.5 states the applicant's property is
now reduced to a level officers consider
acceptable
is it still acceptable if the true
height which in real terms is almost
three quarters of a meter higher than
the height at which the officers base
their view
privacy two of the windows are of
concern
the staircase window and in particular
the nearest bedroom window
which locks over approximately eighty
percent of my garden
at a close distance and now angles
towards it
0.5.7 the agent states it is not
possible to see on the neighbour's rear
garden
a statement that is completely false
it's a point that has been included in
the report but the officers know it is
incorrect
mr kirkham i stood on my garden and
viewed my concerns
in fact saying how would you feel mr tag
if the nearest bedroom window
was obscured and open towards you
i would also like to point out that i
submitted a number of photographs my
from my garden showing my concerns and
the view of the development property
none have been included in this report
point seven point one two it states that
because the penetration
seconds remain sorry 30 seconds remain
okay it states that because the bedroom
windows now sit lower
views will now be considered by officers
acceptable
this is irrelevant because the height of
the bedroom floor is not being lowered
if the floor isn't lowered then anyone
looking out and affecting my privacy
will have the same view and the same
height as before
so from a private privacy aspect nothing
has changed
as the view of my garden is actually the
same is this still considered acceptable
by the offices
thank you mr tag your time is up okay
are there any questions for the speaker
council elliot
thank you chair i i assume yours is the
bungalow below the the lower one that's
correct
and the the velox is that your kitchen
is that feeding light to your kitchen
that's the kitchen yeah okay and you and
there's a dormer in the roof
similar to what this um is proposing on
this site
there is there's a small bathroom about
two meters across it's nothing
to compare to the size and proportion of
this thanks very much
cheers any other questions
no thank you mr tag you can take your
seat
i have one other speaker today and kathy
mcnally
[Applause]
if you'd like to confirm your name and
then you have three minutes
happy mcnally hello i'm kathy mcnally
i'm speaking on behalf of the applicant
to my daughter samantha richmond who's
just had a baby so she couldn't be here
today
and i appreciate mr tagscon concerns and
would like to respond in concern of the
impact of privacy first
after meeting in his garden with mr tag
um i agree that there was
a visibility from this smaller bedroom
window
and the others won't be able to see into
his garden because the amount of
foliage in the the shed and things like
that the small bedroom window he's
concerned about
looks predominantly out over our own
garden and as the planners of detail
following two site visits on our own and
mr tax property
it will have a limited view into his
garden
due to its own garage shed high beach
hedge and our mature trees
the nature of the close proximity to
others on windsor drive and the
surrounding
area inevitably leads to overlooking
gardens to a greater or lesser degree
and therefore therefore we feel that mr
tag's request for obscure glass in the
bedroom window is unnecessary
people don't normally spend a lot of
time looking out of the bedroom windows
usually at a time when people are in bed
or going to bed
being able to look out of a bedroom
window is not an unreasonable request
our builder has built nine other dormer
projects in the nearby vicinity
including mr tag zone loft conversion
and not one was required to have obscure
glass in a rear bedroom window
including the juliet balcony door on the
first floor to the rear of a house on
david's drive which
overlooks numerous gardens we've already
taken steps to improve his privacy by
removing a ground floor window at the
side of our property that looked
directly across the back of his property
and lower garden
as a gesture of goodwill we've also
changed the plans to reduce the height
and the
the size of the aforementioned smaller
bedroom dormer to reduce the impact on
from his side window
the majority of the privacy mr tag
enjoys currently is due to the dense
foliage of the apple trees in our garden
that's the reason why all the subsequent
houses to the
left of our property can't see into his
garden i
feel that the the um what he's worried
about could be addressed through the
additional screening
of planting on the boundary
as suggested on our last meeting with mr
tag
the floor is being lowered we are
lowering the floor we're having to put
the
floors actually attaching now instead of
above the existing
timbers we are actually doing them to
the side so the floor is being loaded
slightly
from the last meeting report um
[Music]
it was basically apart from the
um cladding issue which we've now
changed
um it was reported that in every other
respect they were happy the planners
were happy with everything else
thank you are there any questions for
the speaker
no oh counselor can i just ask obviously
sorry you mentioned that you've got to
lower the floor level
yeah by how much um i think the roof is
being pulled down
um by about 70 centimeters no 50
centimeters i think the roof has been
lowered so
uh we've got to go a minimum so that we
still get that
head height but the the actual room that
overlooks
is sort of in and smaller thank you
thank you any other questions no thank
you mr small
thank you
are there any questions now for the
planning officer council armitage then
council radio
thank you chair uh it's for adrian
really
uh you mentioned that the uh actual plan
will be
uh a meter higher than it already
already is how much higher
will it be than the neighboring property
and have you done that uh thing with a
line showing how much
it encroaches the light
i don't know the the exact detailing um
and the height that
councilor armitage has mentioned here
the best
um i can i can help him with would be to
ask you to look at the the photograph
of this entitled amenity stroke light in
the
pack chair and that shows the
finished roughly the finished floor
level of the bungalow where mr tag lives
you can see the retaining wall and then
you can see the
the air bricks further up so that's the
unfinished floor level of the properties
i understand it
and then if you can imagine that where
you have currently the the guttering
instead of having a hip on the roof
there will just be the gable then that
extends
up from there as per the drawing that
is shown um the proposed plans chair
so you will have you can see the the dpc
level on the
plan that's the hash line and then if
you compare that with the photograph
you'll be able to to see the the issue
of how that will
will look just just in terms of the
side kitchen window check chair
specifically excuse me
the the issue that officers have taken
in respect of that
is that is a secondary window affording
light to the kitchen
and would otherwise have been installed
as part of the works that have been
undertaken to the bungalow and there are
other windows and light
giving light to the kitchen including
the the window that
council and councillor elliot has
mentioned chair
and therefore as officers we've not
placed significant weight on the
existence of that window and the impact
of the extension
on it there's no doubt light getting to
that window
from the extension will be impacted
but officers have placed limited weight
on that because of its
in our in our view it's secondary
importance to
affording light to the kitchen so we've
not afforded that significant weight
in our considerations but of course
members will need to take a view on how
much weight
you afford that window and the light
that it gives to the kitchen
are there any further questions
councillor elliot
just just a quick one with the
discrepancy in the in the
heights but were there were both heists
taken from the date and being the dpc
on both properties did we get the
highest
or the extra height from that you know
we've
we've heard about the six course of
bricks or seven course of bricks
and and so on but with the with the
levels taken from the dpcs
on both properties in terms of
our advice as officers are our
the height we've taken from from offices
is from that
that point yes lovely thank you
any other questions or comments for the
officers
no thank you i'll open the floor for
debate
okay i'll open the floor for a motion
i'll open the floor for a moment then
having heard what i've heard this
afternoon
and seeing the amended plans i'm quite
happy to uh approve
rick officer's recommendation and i'll
second that chair
[Applause]
can i have the roll call for the vote
please thank you chair
councillor rough for castle rouse
council ridgeway or councillor powell
council jones or councillor
thank you the motion has been carried
and if everyone's in favor we'll have a
10 minute break
[Applause]
okay ladies and gentlemen can you take
your seats please and we will resume the
meeting
fourth application this afternoon is
item seven which is ned four stroke two
one four stroke zero zero
zero one six four stroke fl at eckington
and over to the planning members thank
you chair
yes as mentioned the application is to
convert an existing public house and
ancillary buildings to
five apartments
fundamentally the application is
considered by officers to comply with
the
council's change of usa use and
conversions policy
in the respect that it's not considered
there's any significant impact on the
character and appearance of the area
nor is it considered that there are any
adverse impacts on
neighbouring immunity as set out in the
committee report
fundamental policy consideration relates
to the loss of community facilities
policy sh8 of the local plan
and id5 of the emerging local plan
do allow for the loss of social
infrastructure facilities
in circumstances where it can be
demonstrated
there are adequate facilities elsewhere
in the vicinity of the site
in this instance officers consider that
there are adequate alternative
facilities within
a relatively close proximity of the
application site
namely the george inn which is situated
200 metres away
also within the designated town centre
of eckington
also the rosen crown is located at
approximately 800 meters away
and the moss brook albeit slightly
outside the defined settlement
is situated around 700 metres from the
application site
it's considered that these public houses
serve
the same community and are equally
accessible by sustainable modes of
transport
a further consideration relates to the
vitality of the town centre of eckington
whilst it's acknowledged that the loss
of a public house will have some impact
on the town centre
the mppf clearly identifies that
residential development plays an
important role
in ensuring the vitality of centres
officers consider in this instance that
the creation of five households
would in its own way contribute to the
vitality
and vibrancy of heckington town centre
from a heritage perspective there are
limited visual alterations to the
to the existing premises and these are
considered to have a neutral impact on
the conservation area
and the nearby listed buildings in
addition to the main points summarized
there are no technical reasons to refuse
the application
officers therefore recommend that the
application is approved
subject to the conditions detailed in
the officer report to members
moving on to the slideshow um
the first slide as with the previous
applications
details the application site highlighted
in orange
[Applause]
you can see the site's position on the
corner of market street and royal close
with a public car park to the rear the
next slide
um again as with most of the
applications is provided with
a location plan with the premises and
associated land edged in red
moving on to the next slide this is a
site plan which indicates the building
to be
converted the remodeled building to the
wreath single story element
and then parking and maneuvering of
vehicles within the site
the next slide is the existing
elevations of the public house
and the range of buildings to the rear
the following
slide shows the material alterations
being made
to the premises which as you can see are
fairly limited and comprise
alterations to the fenestration and also
the rebuilding of those those
single-story range of buildings to
create an additional residential unit
moving on to the photos the first photo
shows the junction of royal close
and market street
the next photo is taken from the rear of
the premises
and shows the rear of the two-story
element of the public house
and in addition the range of
single-story buildings at the rear
which are earmarked for demolition and
rebuilding
and the final photo shows the principal
elevation of the
premises taken from the corner of market
street and real close and that concludes
the presentation thank you
thank you i shall ask for the speakers
now
we only have one speaker and that's the
agent linda trollope
if you'd like to take the table
if you'd like to confirm your name and
then you have three minutes
i'd like to say support the officer's
recommendation
i appreciate that the site is within the
designated town centre of eckington
in both the adopted and publication
draft local plans
and that policies do seek to resist the
loss of local facilities
unless there are adequate alternative
facilities elsewhere and it can be
demonstrated that there is no demand for
such a facility in the area
both of these tests are met in this case
let's notice
as noted by the officer there are other
public houses within easy reach of this
site
the pub has been closed since 2018
and even before that date was fairly
barely viable
it was on sale for a year after that
time and then went to auction but there
was no interest in the building
eckington parish council applied to this
council
for the building to be listed as an
asset of community value
which is a procedure where a local
organization can ask for a building to
be put on a list of assets of community
value
which if the asset comes up for sale
gives them up to six months in which to
raise capital
and bid to buy the asset before it can
be disposed of on the open market
that application was refused by this
council as the decision taker was not
satisfied
that the asset had provided community
value currently
or in the recent past that situation is
no different
now the current applicant bought it in
2019
and immediately after this the building
was entered unlawfully and vandalized
with any items of value being removed
so further reducing the viability of the
building for a public house use
in addition to local policy national
policy advice is also relevant
recent government guidance has
emphasized the advantages of residential
development in town centres
in promoting the vitality of the centre
and increasing housing supply
this has been put into legislation by
the designation
of the change of use of a range of local
facilities such as shops
offices restaurants and cafes to
residential use
as being permitted development and
there's also been recent advice
on restricting the use of article 4
directions
which could override these permitted
development rights
in conclusion the site is in a
sustainable location within the built
up area of eckington the lack of demand
for a public house here has been shown
30 seconds
remains by its lack of viability and the
lack of interest in its sail
currently it is attracting vandalism and
anti-social behavior
and detracting from the vitality and
viability of the centre
the development has been designed to be
in keeping with the character of the
conservation area
all in accordance with policy
thank you are there any questions
no thank you you can take a seat
are there any questions for the planning
offices
council armitage yeah thank you jer
it was just for agent what sort of size
are these uh apartments
um i mean do they fit the criteria or
are they more substantial or are they
less substantial
in size
colleen may be able to to add chair but
they all the
the five apartments are proposed as two
bedded
apartments and in terms of providing
reasonable levels of accommodation share
from looking at the
the plans like my view would be that
they would provide appropriate
two breaded two-bedded accommodation for
a town centre chair
thank you any other questions
adrian this this is uh this is quickly
it's only because of so much detail on
that plan i can't see it
i see the i see the hammerhead and the
turning circle for cars
but unless i'm mistaken i can't see
where the parking is
for the buildings and that might just be
me being a bit
blind i don't know if i can help with
this it is quite
a busy plan yeah i appreciate that i
think at this at this scale it's quite
difficult to uh
to fully understand it um there is
parking provision for
five um cars within the the existing
car park and yard area um it's difficult
to
to identify where they are but there are
parking spaces on the
the western edges of the site as you
look at it oh i don't know if it's
western actually but on the
basis on the left-hand side of the the
block plan as you look at
it and there'd be additional parking at
the front edge
um highways raised no objections
um as a consultant and given that it's a
town centre location it's obviously
considered by
well it is considered by officers to be
accessible by sustainable mode of
transport as well so
there would be a parking space for each
of the um the units
yeah i'd say it was just a busy it's a
busy slide so i could see the turning
opportunity but i couldn't see the
spaces yeah but i'll see where you say i
think it's all
in red virtually yeah so to answer your
question there's a parking space for
each of the units
so one car per property yeah that's
right yeah
okay thank you yeah any further
questions
comments cancel a pound
no just moving your microphone heads
get well i should open the floor to
debate
if there is any councillor ridgeway
um yes i am i wholeheartedly agree with
this plan
and i will definitely be going with
officer's recommendation
this has been standing in eckington for
a long long time
it's been empty and when it as um linda
trollope has said
it's been a bone of contention for quite
a long time
even when it was a pub there was lots of
violence
the police tried to work with the the
landlords of the pub
and they weren't successful even
northeast derbyshire did
there were lots of problems and to see
it being
used to be turned into accommodation
will be
really good because otherwise it's just
standing there being derelict so i will
actually be going with office's
recommendation on this
thank you any other questions comments
no
well i'll open the floor for a motion
then
i'll move off to the recommendation
thank you seconded thank you
and we'd have a roll call thank you um
councillor ralph for councillor rouse
for council ridgeway or
that's unanimous chair thank you the
motion's been carried we'll move on to
the next application
and this is ned forward slash 21 forward
zero zero one three nine forward slash
fl
morton i'll hand over to the planning
officer
thank you chad may i firstly confirm
that no late reps have been received on
this application
in terms of detailing this is a full
application for the demolition of an
existing single story outbuilding
and the erection of a detached dwelling
with associated garden and parking at 2
stretton road morton
members of planning committee attended a
virtual site visit where we saw
a number of photos of the site
now draw members attention to point 2.7
of the report which makes reference to
the walling material as natural coarse
stone
this is incorrect the material will in
fact be natural blend brick
a key update for members is that the
applicant has commenced works on site
and the dwelling is almost complete
irrespective of the state of the
building there is no reason why the
application could not be determined this
afternoon
officers consider that the proposal
would be in keeping with the character
and appearance of the
site and surrounding street scene there
would be no detrimental impact upon
neighbouring properties amenity
conservation area or highway safety
matters relating to ecology drainage and
ground stability can be addressed
through conditions
as you can see in the pack chair the
plan illustrates the site shaded in
orange the site is located to the north
of stretton road and falls within both
the moreton conservation area and
settlement development limit this next
slide shows the proposed block plan the
dwelling would be cited on the footprint
of the outbuilding and the detached
garage
sited within the north west corner of
the site
access would be taken via the existing
access point off stretton road
this next slide is an elevation and
floor plan of the proposed two-story
four-bedroom detached dwelling
on the next slide here we have an
elevation floor plan of the garage
the next few slides are key photos taken
from the committee site visit which
members attended yesterday i've included
these as a refresher for members
that concludes the presentation thank
you chair
thank you there are no speakers on this
application at all
so i'll go straight to questions for
planning officer
councillor armitage yes
uh as you said
this building uh is uh now
complete just about uh so
why don't we have the photograph of the
completed building
uh instead of the shell of
the building to be demolished i mean we
could have got some
uh well some idea of the size and the
scale of it
and i was a bit well
at a loss really because we didn't have
the photograph of the building
and it's also down uh as
uh not as a uh
a retrospective one which it obviously
is
and you know i just feel a lot of the
information
is missing from the actual uh plan which
we've been shown here
and you know i don't know i mean
i would have liked to see the proper
picture so we could have had a look
on whether or not it's
you know the impact on the the
great two listed holy cross church
and this sort of thing because it is
quite a tall building this new one
because i saw it yesterday and
you know i'm sorry but i found it
lacking the information the photographic
information which would be given and it
does appear to be inaccurate
when the building is standing
retrospective sorry chief i can just
come back to council i'm teacher
initially on some of those points and
then if
emily's got anything to actually i'm
sure she will but in terms of the
application before you chair it's an
application to erect a
two-story property and that doesn't
alter whether the building's
um partly constructed fully constructed
or not constructed or that's still the
issue that members need to take into
account
the photos that we've included in the
pack chair of those
of officers when we visited the site and
i acknowledge
entirely what councilor armenti said
that the the site has changed
since then indeed the building it to my
mind when i viewed it like yesterday
afternoon when to be brought to our
attention is
is almost complete it's always
regrettable chair we
would prefer development to seek consent
and get consent
appropriately then be built as such but
the fact that the building may be there
is regrettable but isn't the turning
point that you should be considering you
need still to consider
the the planning issues and the impact
on nearby heritage assets as councilor
armitage has said
is one of those issues and and the
comments of officers are set out in the
report
chair so from from an office point of
view we've sought to put in the
the pack information to help members the
fact that the photographs were taken on
the officer
site visit and things have changed on
site since then
um it's not in my my view chair
something that should be
criticized of officers we sought to
provide the information that
that members need to make the decision
of course the plans
on slide three of the presentation that
emily's just gone through
do actually show the building as a
fateful reproduction of actually what
is being constructed on site to chair
thank you
emily do you want to could i come back
to you on that i'm just going to ask
emily if she wants to add to that
no i think adrian's covered everything
thank you okay counselor armitage
is the site is the application
retrospective
or not that's what i'm trying to get at
considering the buildings there
i think from that point of view chair
the applicant is seeking to
retain what's been built and complete it
so from that point of view development
has started however you
you can't say anything different chair
the building is in to my viewing
almost complete certainly is the shell
on site so the applicant is seeking to
retain
what's been built but ultimately what
planning committee need to consider this
afternoon is whether the erection of a
two-story property
in the position of the design shown in
the drawings is acceptable
if it is chair you should be granting
permission potentially subject to
conditions
if it's not then you would need to
consider it and
refuse the application for sound
planning reasons the fact it's there
is is always regrettable but that
doesn't and shouldn't count against the
application in the way
you attribute to the various planning
issues
thank you
i actually flagged this up yesterday
with the officers
because of information i'd received and
whilst i'm not happy that the building
has
already commenced i have taken legal
advice from our legal team
and we actually just judged this
application
as it stands i can't go back to it as
being retrospective
but we judge it as it is put before us
today
any other questions or comments
counselor ridgeway i find that quite
quite difficult because
as council armitages says we've you know
we're looking at pictures of it before
it's even erected
and in my eyes this is a retrospective
planning
you know consideration that we have to
make
and i wholeheartedly disagree with
respect you know retrospective ones
if they can't abide by the law then i
think they should be made to knock it
down
come back and go through the proper
channels that's my own personal
opinion but i think it is wrong that
we've been given all these pictures
and the building is up and up and
running and it is as far as i'm
concerned retrospective
thank you any other councillor elliot
yeah it's just a comment really
and and it is just to say that
retrospective isn't against the law
they're just taking it in their own
hands whether or not we say you're
taking it down or not so
they've not done anything wrong in that
respect retrospective's not
not something we have to worry about
unless we unless they've got no
permission at all
just if i can add to that checkers um i
can only reaffirm what council eliot
said chad that the planning issues
remain do you consider what's proposed
on this site
acceptable or not in planning terms if
you do
you should granted permission as i say
potentially with conditions if you don't
for planning reasons
then you should refuse it but what you
shouldn't weigh in the balance is the
fact that
for all intents and purposes the very
least the shell is almost complete
and doesn't fall within your
consideration you need as counselor
elliott's
rightly said chair you need to
concentrate on the planning issues which
are the same whether it's been built
or whether it's not been built thank you
any other comment question
check can i adrian can i just ask you
that's twice now you've said
um leave the condition worry about the
conditions
what conditions are you actually
alluding to there please
the officers have recommended various
conditions set out at page 86 of your
pack
as we normally do and if members are
minded to grant permission we would
recommend that those conditions are
attached but of course
um conditions the imposition of them is
a matter for the decision maker
so that that falls to the planning
committee this afternoon but our
recommendation
is to grant consent subject to those
conditions we'll not
worry about number one then
that's a that's a fair point to
australia yes
adrian it's not fit for purpose yet it's
not fit for
um people to live in it yet is it as i
say chair further to your
um correspondence with officers
yesterday i did go past the site myself
later on yesterday afternoon
no you wouldn't live in it as it stands
but um the shell is
is pretty much complete but just just to
i don't want to label the point here but
i'll make this final point that
as officers we've sought to include in
the pack information that we believed
was appropriate in helping members
to make the decision we weren't aware
that the building works
were at this state they were so we've
not sought in any way to
underplay that not to include
information that we knew was was
incorrect
okay thank you if there's no further
questions
i'll open the floor for debate and
comment
that's really it i'm not going to go for
the debate
if you want to go straight to emotion
that's fine by me yeah i think we've
deliberated
with it long enough and i accept what
our officers are telling us
so i'd like to move we go with officer
recommendation please
i'll second that at council of powell
sorry
if we are debating i would just say that
um it's another case where we've been
backed into a corner i think
um i think it is very regrettable uh
that
it's been started but in planning terms
we have no choice
and and we've got to uh to respect
what we have to do so i will second it
if you haven't already
that's fine thank you okay so we've got
a proposal and second uh
i'll go for the vote thank you
councillor ruff
for casa rouse four councillor ridgeway
i'm abstaining castle powell
council jones abstain
council elliott casa dayton
for council armitage abstain
council and cliff paul jeff that's six
votes four zero
against three abstentions it's carried
thank you the motions carried
for the last item on our agenda today is
the planning commit for the planning
committee is tpo
for clay lane chair thank you yes
um as we discussed i think a couple of
committees ago
um where provisional tree preservation
orders have been made
and objections have been received to
their confirmation there's a matter for
planning committee to
consider whether to confirm the order
has made modify
it and confirm it in a modified form or
to not confirm the order chair that this
is a
report to that and to that respect
and in this instance chair two area
tpos were made on trees on a site
granted planning permission
in early um 2021
and they comprise the areas a1 and a2 on
page 90 of your packs
and fundamentally chair further to the
comments of the
parish council officers are recommending
that instead of area a2
incorporating a small area outside the
development site share that the boundary
is redrawn
along the site boundary with a footpath
and that therefore that we
hope as officers that addresses the
parish council's concern about any
suggestion that trees outside the area
and within the
council parish council owned allotment
gardens are covered by the order
it's not normal procedure chair for the
council to make
tpos on trees that are owned or managed
by what would be known as an appropriate
authority to
ourselves the county council parish
councils etc
so that's the the officer recommendation
chair and just to
seek to provide some background for
members and i've got some pictures of
the trees in the pack
and the first slide shows the the trees
subject of area a1 beyond where the
bricks are currently stored
and similarly in slide
two beyond where the cabin is stored the
trees along the pressed brook
are included in the order moving on to
slide three that's now a slide looking
up
clay lane towards area a2
slide 4 is looking back across the site
towards the
trees comprising area a1 adjoining
press brook and you can just make out
beyond chair
dwellings that occupy land off
windermere road
[Applause]
coming through to the next slide there's
a public footpath that the parish
council
um a lieutenant which divides the
allotment guards in the development site
and slide five shows that
footpath looking back south towards
trees comprising area a2 with the
development site on the right hand side
there
next slide is simile of a view of the
site from that footpath but now looking
towards
the trees comprising area a1 which are
the trees in the background
and then finally chair the final
two slides again another one looking
from the footpath
through area a2 towards the trees in the
background which comprise area a1
and the final slide chair exemplifies
the points made by the parish council
that is the line of the public footpath
the
area beyond the harris fencing the trees
comprised in
area a2 which would still be covered by
the order
the trees on the right hand side are
trees located
in or around the allotment gardens the
parish council
is seeking um clarification they don't
form part of the order and hence the
the officer recommendation to confirm
the order in its modified form
thank you chair thank you we have two
speakers on this application and i do
thank you for your forbearance and
patience
um and the first name i have is mr
richard park if you'd like to confirm
your name and then you have three
minutes
richard barge right in relation to
uh area a1 on the tree preservation
order
my property uh backs on to that
particular tree row we are
approximately currently about five
meters lower than the
proposed development site now there's
also
um a requirement with within the
development to
raise that site at least 0.65 or a meter
so i've got a big issue with privacy now
these trees
afford us some degree of privacy uh from
that
uh from that side of the river um and
also in that area there's a proposed
car turning circle which will then
see headlights at night overlooking my
property and others
which again is a you know an issue the
other issues i've got with this is
basically these trees are lined the bank
and
are mostly down the bank so there's no
uh necessity to remove them anyway
because
they're not impacting on the uh
well the disputed border because uh it
has been
stated by derbyshire wildlife trust that
this 10 meters
wildlife corridor should be left now the
developers within a zoom meeting with
the residents saying they could come as
far
onto the river bank as they as they want
and these
issues there with otters uh they should
be auto mitigation strategy and what's
not happened
and also water bowls way i'm looking at
it is there
the only reason they want to remove
these trees is for liabilities and avoid
maintenance costs going forward
now currently the
looking from my rear guard and recently
as last
friday evening there's a bat feeding
zone within
these trees you can sit and watch the
bats uh
going round it there's all sorts of
wildlife been displaced from the orchard
what were remove
in january of this year for no good
reason so
currently that's supporting a large
wildlife habitat
and in relation to what government
advice is in bat
feeding areas this
activity will removing uh commuting
habitats air drills
against watercourses and woodland will
obviously impact bats which are as we
aware as a protective species
and changing or removing back foraging
areas which again
um basically 30 seconds remain
right and basically uh as we all know
trees catch capture carbon and give off
oxygen
we bang on about people removing
deforestation
now obviously this is on a much smaller
scale but there's just no need
for this to be these trees to be removed
when they're they're doing a brilliant
job what they what they're designed to
do and
basically for no good reason these trees
are
you know are being removed so that's
uh that's why i feel so passionately
about it so
hopefully we'll be supported and
keep the trees really belong thank you
if you wait there in case there's any
questions
are there any questions councillor
ridgeway
yeah i was reading in the pack here it
says that some of the trees have already
been filled is that right that's correct
in particular in zone a1
um for some reason there's been a whole
thorn bush removed now this has been
reported back to council
and there was some sort of excuse they
didn't fall within that term
in the tree protection order but it was
part of that edge row
and one of them was removed probably
six eight weeks ago something like that
after this three reservoir
reservations excuse me tree preservation
order was in force
uh the developer took them on itself i
would privy to a
conversation between the site manager
and the hired ecologist in relation to
what trees they were going to remove
that's another issue because this this
discharging surface water
into the press brook now these
spaces in that edge row where they could
have done that quite easily without
removing any trees but they've chosen
otherwise
and just using any sort of excuses now
we've seen what's happened in germany
and belgium this week
in relation to what's in our classroom
as soil
removing soil ceiling and what impact
that's having
and you know that's been widely reported
in the press over the last week or so so
yeah
so yes that has been already reached
let's answer your question any other
questions
no thank you
the next speaker is mr richard eden
[Applause]
if you'd just like to confirm your name
and then you have three minutes
richard eden uh right so basically
i'll go back to what mr barges said
there uh derbyshire wildlife trust had
already made an agreement with the
developer
on what they could remove and what they
couldn't remove
the developer did say that they were
going to enhance the orchard what was
already there
but the developer has already removed
more
well all of the fruit trees totally now
they have actually been in touch with
planning
derbyshire wildlife trust and stated
that it's not acceptable what they've
already moved
now the buffer zone in a1 the wildlife
buffer zone which is
has got the otters the voles the
kingfishers and what have you
er they have now put another revised
planning application in
and they've they've drawn their buffer
zone up
from within our boundaries our boundary
actually goes into three quarters of
press broke
and they've actually done that now that
means they're going to take some of
these
trees out on the tree preservation order
on a1
which we've said is not acceptable since
they've felt the orchard a lot of the
wildlife
has come into those trees because
they've got nowhere else to go
if they start removing them trees on
that bank side
they was putting in the 80s by the
residents of windermere road asked
for them to be put in the council put
them in for prevention the flood so the
trees could
drink the water and prevent the flood
risk now
now they're wanting to remove those
trees and obviously
they've been there 40 years and it's
built a wildlife zone up there for
wildlife
if they start removing them out of the
bank it's going to affect the otters
they've said there's got to be 10 meters
from the top of the bank on their side
for the otters and they're coming in
within that
now also you can imagine ripping roots
up
there's kingfishers that nest in the
banks
and everything uh obviously there's the
privacy as well and security
like the development is going to be four
meters either in our our buildings
and we're going to be liking a goldfish
ball they're going to be looking down on
us
we need that that previous to that
development starting
that was our security there was no way
into our back boundaries but
but by that development now that's
opened all that area
up so without those trees as well
that gives speculation for criminals to
come onto our back gardens
that's that's about it thank you thank
you are there any questions
no thank you very much
i'll now move forward any questions to
the planning officers
counselor elliot adrian i don't suppose
it's
as much a question as a statement really
i remember this application going
through
and i i can't say any better than the
two speakers have said it
but the we we i'm fairly confident said
that all those trees on the
periphery of that development must stay
not only for the privacy reasons
but to sustain the bank and as these
have rightly said
to stop the bank falling in in times of
flood because it was only a narrow brook
and i seem to remember the agent saying
at some point that they were going to
scrape the brook out so it was it says
it would actually take the water and the
flood risk
away but the the trees for me
imperative this day
so it wasn't so much of a question
adrian i apologize i can make it one if
you want
i'll forgive you anyone else
counselor obviously mr barge and
mr eden reverted to the bats do we know
i mean in
modern houses these days they actually
in the brickwork they actually
do bat houses within the brickwork
do we know if that's going to happen
without having the permission and the
conditions here chair i'm afraid i don't
know
um if this um i'd have to check the
conditions in terms of what is required
for ecology but i can
i can advise council arouse further to
this meeting if you'd like me to chair
yeah that'd be lovely that's
only where i could answer the question
but i'll write to you and let you know
about that okay yeah
thank you that's right cliff adrian this
might sound rather silly but
if they've taken trees outdoor hedgerow
should they not be
put back the the issue that was
mentioned in relation to the the tree um
by the speakers
and the information that i have is that
my colleague the enforcement officer did
go and investigate that issue with the
developers and his view was
that for whatever reason it wasn't a
tree that was was covered by the order
now
that's coming to me from discussing that
with the site owner
but other than that if trees are removed
then yes
that would be if it contrary to a tpo
then that would be a
an offence that the council could
prosecute should it choose to do so
the the issue about an area order is it
will only be
sufficient in the relatively short term
to protect the trees because
they should be reviewed and revised
within a relatively short period of time
because
the area tpos are only protected with
trees in place at the time the order is
made
so within a relatively short period of
time we will need to go and resurvey the
trees to
and put them in a modified order groups
or single trees or woodland trees
but um in short chair trees are removed
that are otherwise protected the council
can
prosecute the removal of those trees if
he chooses to do so
that is the other alternative yes and
that may be um
part of the the mitigation mediation
that takes place if trees are removed
elsewhere jones i was going to put the
same point really
and i want to know what sanctions can be
taken because if we let
people demolish the trees willy-nilly
when we've already got an order
it's just not on and i wonder what we
can do about
it because we may have to make an
example of this because it's not just
happening on this site
and we're looking for things like we're
supposed to
uh respect the birds nesting they don't
respect that the trees go
and i'm quite worried about it and with
global warming
you know we made a commitment to that in
this district council that we
take it seriously and chopping trees
down
that are not in the way of actually the
structures that's going up
on a bank out just totally against them
being removed
just just to comment on that just to
clarify to members that
the report before you this this
afternoon is seeking a view from members
on whether you wish to confirm
or not the order so in terms of this
report chair
the issue for members is is relatively
straightforward
yay or nay and officers are recommending
that it is in that slightly modified
form in respect of the
comments that the parish council has
made i note the comments that members
are
are making here the the purpose of this
order is to ensure that further trees
from this site
aren't removed and what has been said
it's true that a number of trees
have been removed from the site but not
trees that were protected at that time
so
as far as officers and there's been no
offence so far
but if the trees were removed should
members confirm the order this afternoon
then yes
if they were removed then an offence has
been
has been undertaken and it is for the
council then to to decide whether to
prosecute
but all those elements that members are
making here ecology
and you've heard about amenity they're
all issues that you can take into
account in
your decision this afternoon thank you
are there any council armitage
thank you chair i saw this site uh
in april uh the orchard
uh had been ripped out it was
uh put into a big heap and set on fire
and this was after the end of march
uh time when uh birds was
were nesting as far as i'm concerned
this uh
tree preservation order should be
upheld and also the other one as well
and if any trees were taken out
whether they were covered by this or not
then i feel
i know it's not a planning matter but i
feel that
they should be prosecuted because it was
basically i've never seen such a mess
and the people on windermere road uh had
to stand by and not
only that i feel their their nose rubbed
in it because they lit the fires and the
fires were smoldering for days and i had
to call environmental health
along to sort it out and
i think i will be voting
to extend this tree preservation
order thank you we've had lots of
comments so do i need to open the floor
for debate or move straight to emotion
announcer armitage yeah i go along with
officers recommendation
and i'll second that chair thank you
have a vote please
check can we can we say that through
through the
motions that we make sure the conditions
are on that they put trees back that are
moved or
got rid of certainly that because that's
what i want to see and i don't mean a
sapling back with a piece of
wood yeah a bit of tube but i want to
see mature trees
that's what they've demolished thank you
there's a full management
order put on for the for the whole of
these
trees okay can i second that chair i
wholeheartedly agree
i've voiced my concerns before in this
planning committee about trees being
chopped down willy-nilly
i think every every planning application
as far as i'm concerned
that comes along with trees on those
trees should be protected
because they were here long before we uh
and they'll be here a lot longer than
some of these houses that will be
being built but yes and i also think
that we should be asking that the hedge
that has been taken out
that something else is replaced it put
back in that place as well
because as far as i'm concerned a hedge
or a tree they're the same thing
thank you okay so
so we just cleared on that chair appears
to be to re
um to approve the order in line with
officer recommendations
subject to the conditions uh the
modifications which are adrian's
referred to
and then also with a full management
order
for the trees and in particular members
expressed a desire that
any restoration of trees should be made
with
mature trees rather than saplings
is that the essence of it members and is
that okay about you
adrian in terms of your understanding
just in terms of that show
we need to differentiate between the the
order itself which is which is very
clear there's only certain things that
we can
impose with in relation to a tree
preservation or that protects the trees
what we can't do
is demand that they are managed in a
particular way what it does allow the
council to have control over how
any felling and replanting takes place
here so
we have very limited powers in respect
to that and in respect to
the wider site that would be taken up
with the the landscaping of the site
and without um checking back the records
the
landscaping scheme for the site may well
already have been approved in terms of
planting
hedgerow planting et cetera so again we
may not be able to row back on that
chair can i ask you a question when we
went back to the
when we originally put that site through
for for planning adrian
i've got a feeling that mention was made
of the orchard and they were keeping it
that's right so if if they keep it and
they've taken it out surely we should be
enforcing that anyway again share
without
um without the information
for me i can't be clear on that but
those issues
will have been addressed i believe as
part of the landscaping of the site but
again
i can find that out and advise counselor
elliot if that would
help check i don't want to overstate
what we can do
through this resolution chair all we can
do in terms of the tpo is
protect the trees the subject of the
order we aren't able to go beyond that
i'm afraid and relax and other things
that may have
been agreed or taken place but if
council will commit the
chair i'll i'll write to him with what
has been agreed and where we are with
the landscaping of the site
yep okay
so that essential adventure is to
approve
the uh order um along the conditions set
out in the report
yeah okay we'll have to go to the vote
councillor
four castle rouse four castle ridgeway
castle powell council jones four
councillor elliot four casa dayton
or cancer armitage for
council and cliff ball that's unanimous
chair thank you the motion's been passed
thank you very much gentlemen you can
remove yourself
for a long haul thank you we're moving
on to
item 11 planning appeals lodged and
determined
if i can just ask members just for a few
minutes just to go through some of the
the appeals chair you'll have seen we've
had a bumper crop
over the past four weeks there's been a
number of outstanding appeals that
decisions have come in relatively
recently and
i hope all members are receiving the
appeal decisions chair because they make
some interesting reading and
there's been some interesting decisions
relatively recently
um i want to pick out one or two if i
may and raise one or two points that i
hopefully will be
helpful in members making decisions on
applications going forwards
the first one i just wanted to to raise
was the first one under appeals allowed
which is the
scout hut at homes field
in particular chair in that instance the
inspector it was interesting what the
inspector came to the conclusion on in
terms of very special circumstances
having taken the view that the
development was unauthorized
sorry inappropriate developed in the
green belt the inspector placed great
weight on the fact that the building was
to be used by
a local scout group and he particularly
tied it back to
the benefits of such facilities
during coving chairs so very interesting
view that was taken by the inspector on
on that although fundamentally
he agreed with the council that it was
inappropriate development but the the
weight placed on those very special
circumstances was was different
um next one i'd like to make reference
to is
mr gill which is the second one on page
96 and this was a decision taken
under officer delegated powers but it is
for a
new dwelling and wingworth members i'm
sure will know
where the site is but it was for a new
dwelling outside settlement limits
and members may recall the consideration
we had of the application at calo
last time whereby we had similar
arguments about new housing developed
outside settlement limits
and i would encourage members to read
that decision because although they
didn't agree with officers
the decision is well reasoned and uses
the reasoning that we put to members
in respect of the kalo application last
time round so it
and it makes the point that developed
outside settlement limits is not
necessarily
inappropriate and unacceptable you need
to take one step further so i would
encourage members to
have a particular look at that site and
the next one chair
is um on page 97 and that's cartilage
hall farm
which went to an informal hearing and
again members may recall the debate we
had about
that site which is again developed in
the green belt and officers took the
view that
again inappropriate development but that
was outweighed by the benefits to the
conservation area
the inspector took a different view
again inappropriate development but he
didn't feel
i believe it was a he that may have been
issued but anyway the inspector didn't
agree that the circumstances and
improvements to the buildings in the
conservation area outweighed that time
so again another very interesting
decision
the next one is the two appeals at
renishaw hall
again members may recall the long debate
about
that application that we had at planning
committee it's some time ago now
interestingly that appeal
was part of a four-day informal hearing
and the inspector went into great detail
about the heritage impacts
on the listed buildings in the
conservation area and particularly
the registered hall and garden of
renishaw hall
it's quite a lengthy appeal decision but
again i'd encourage members to read that
and to have some understanding of the
depth with which an inspector went into
the various elements
of that appeal um again a very well
reasoned
um decision the next one share is mr
lynch page 97 the bottom of there
which was for a very limited first um
building within the the greenbelt a
gazebo which the inspector
dismissed um and again took the view
inappropriate developed in the greenbelt
particularly
conspicuous location and didn't believe
that there were very special
circumstances that outweighed that so so
again
if you're reading all these together
hopefully they're giving you a flavor of
the
issues that you you need to take into
account when
considering applications in greenbelt
heritage assets etc
and finally chair the two at the top of
page
98 well almost finally the two at the
top page 98 westington park
and mr mrs bedford again members will
recall the
the detailed discussions and debate that
took place in planning committee at both
of those
the interesting thing about both of
those decisions
is the weight that inspectors are
placing on
the designation of areas of multiple
environmental sensitivity
in your publication draft local plan the
special landscape area designation will
disappear
when you adopt your new local plan but
the inspector
is placing great weight on the aims as
we
we're knowing them so the areas of
multiple environmental sensitivity
which is set out in your publication
draft local plan
again two very interesting decisions
that came forward and just finally
just to conclude with mr merriman we're
very pleased with the
enforcement notice appeal at um
at border view farm a number of appeals
a number of unauthorized developments
and we're very pleased that
the council secured a dismissal on the
most important elements of that appeal
so
it's a lot of reading chair but they are
very interesting
in terms of how inspectors are viewing
decisions exactly the way that we
should just some of them are
particularly well argued
and do take some some reading but but
well worth
half an hour after coronation street
tomorrow night chair perhaps
anyone still watch that is it still
going
i've no idea
i'm happy to take any questions share
but um but hopefully that's a useful
canter through those those decisions
thank you
any comments no
i've no matters of urgency so i thank
you all for attending this afternoon and
a safe journey home
you